einfach in badra herzlich willkommen wir
heute auf jeden fall zu einem neuen
video auf meinem kanal weiter lieben
freunde ihr seht schon ich bin immer
noch gewappnet gegen die in corona virus
jetzt dann habe ich ja bereits ein video
hier auf meinem kanal hochgeladen zum
corona virus wo ich euch einfach erklärt
habe was der virus ist und euch einfach
mal gedacht habe macht euch nicht so
verrückt natürlich schlachten die medien
das thema aus weil es einfach das cliq
thema als schlechthin gerade deswegen
allerdings bin ich auf jeden fall mal
die kommentare unter meinem gestrigen
corona virus video durchgegangen und
haben sehr viele leute geschrieben luca
spiel doch mal plugin falls ihr euch
jetzt frage sollte etwas platt gegen die
überhaupt ist das ist ein spiel
beziehungsweise vielmehr eine taktische
simulation wo es darum geht in die
komplette menschheit auszurotten
also quasi corona virus als spieler also
bevor jetzt hier auch wieder leute
ankommen und sagen boah luca nur edelste
voll kleiner wissen wir ob man wird
krank das ist freude für mich solche
kommentare kamen nämlich teilweise unter
meinem gestrigen video und nein ich
möchte das überhaupt nicht kleinreden
oder mich darüber lustig machen über den
virus um gottes willen ich wollte mich
nur wenn die leute ein bisschen lustig
machen die so völlig in panik
ausgebrochen sind
die sterberate beim corona virus ist
geringer als bei den meisten anderen
viren die davor in die runde gemacht
haben beispielsweise saß oder mails oder
mars oder die sterberate beim corona
virus liegt bei zwei prozent
natürlich klar das ist immer noch jeder
fünfzigste aber alle leute die bisher
daran gestorben sind hatten
vorerkrankungen waren extrem alt rauchen
machen wenig sport haben schlechte
immunsystem hatten vor erkrankte herzen
hatte macht euch da bitte wirklich keine
großen sorgen freude solange ich den
ganzen tag in eurem keller laufen sitzt
und schimmel einatmet und zum frühstück
eine ratte fress und zum nachtisch dann
irgendwie noch eine fledermaus dann
sollte euch eigentlich nichts passieren
wenn man normales leben führt und ein
gesunder mensch ist dann besiegt der
körper dieses virus mit null komma
nichts diesen kommentar habe ich heute
beispielsweise mit einem interview von
einer person von der whu gelesen also
wenn ihr euch das durchlesen wollten
einfach mal auf pause und das beschreibt
meiner ansicht eigentlich ganz gut
minute allerdings auf das heutige video
thema zu sprechen und zwar plugin das
ist ein spiel wie ich gerade schon
gesagt habe wo es darum geht dass man
einen virus in eine person einsetzt
irgendwo auf der welt und aufgrund von
irgendwelchen kita hat taktisch klug
ausgewählten schritten und weitergeben
möglichkeiten muss dann die ganze welt
infizieren und schlussendlich töten
ja das spiel hat auf jeden fall so krass
an bekanntheit gewonnen wegen dem corona
virus weil sehr viele leute sich dann
dachten corona virus da kann ich selbst
ein virus machen das spiel hatte ich mir
doch mal runter daraufhin haben die
entwickler von plugin allerdings dass
hier auf ihrer website gepostet und da
wir alle dumm sind und kein englisch
können schauen wir uns dass man auf
deutsch natürlich ebenfalls wieder
erreichen
vor dem spiel hatte er nämlich mit
kräftiger eine fehlinformation sie hat
von lokalen unterbrochen
ja das haben auf jeden fall die
entwickler von plugin gepostet nachdem
das spiel millionenfach heruntergeladen
wurde seit dem ausbruch des corona virus
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir
spielen heute mal das benutzerdefinierte
szenario 2020 johann corona virus hier
sehen ja auf jeden fall schon mal
unseren corona virus eingeblendet am
ticken einfach mal direkt auf fortfahren
wir machen das für erfahrene genetische
stative machen mega brutal für spieler
die dachten brutal wäre ein verehrte
also das bin wirklich ich hier nennen
unsere solche einfach und wirklich mal
corona virus weil es einfach am meisten
sinn macht anklicken jetzt mal
aufspielen workers uaw incontrol ob
disney virus nejm 2009 die cvp war ja
das ist nämlich das ding
das war wirklich fledermäuse die diese
scheiße in umlauf gebracht dann
irgendwelche chinesen hier stehen auch
dass der korona wir uns relativ ähnlich
dem sars virus ist den es ja vor einigen
monaten oder jahren gab
allerdings geht es jetzt los wir sehen
das ist unsere welt die hat eine
bevölkerung von sieben milliarden 124
millionen 543900 ihr seht ihr
deutschland und wir sind verbunden mit
der außenwelt über einen flughafen hier
vorne an
dass wir vorne china und wir blicken
jetzt einfach mal auf play das heißt
losgeht wir sehen schon infiziert sind
14 15 millionen 16 17 millionen 8 ducati
wären direkt 17 millionen infizierte
ganz kurz bevor das video jetzt gleich
im moment weiter geht uns war ich selber
neues bild auf instagram hochgeladen ich
heiß auf instagram laser lokal so geht
gerne mal auf mein foto und kommentiert
corona ich werde versuchen alle
kommentare zum ersten mal aber im
endeffekt niemand tipp doppelpunkt
verwendet der esa ich brauche keine
tipps träger spiel auf brutale okay also
werden sich auf jeden fall ein paar
sachen hier da wird es wieder weiter er
breite ausgebreitet wir sehen hier unten
wir haben schon 21 dns punkte der
messpunkt das ist relativ einfach und
zwar können wir damit unseren virus so
ein bisschen verändern beziehungsweise
sagen wie er sich ausbreiten soll wir
[Musik]
auf jeden fall können wir jetzt hier
unten einfach mal auf unsere krankheit
draufklicken und haben jetzt
verschiedene auf leder aus der kleine
alter das jetzt auf jeden fall unser
übersicht bildschirm wir sehen hier
schon eine kurve die direkt hochgegangen
ist das ist nämlich die
ansteckungsgefahr hier unten rechts das
hier ist die schwere der krankheit ist
auch relativ geringe und die tätlichkeit
ist noch bei null
weil noch niemand daran gestorben ist
leider in unserer krankheit hört sich
irgendwie komisch und dass ich traurig
darüber bin dass noch niemand an unsere
krankheit gestorben ist allerdings ist
das ganze ja nur ein spiel von etlichen
jetzt einfach mal auf übertragung und
können jetzt unsere dns punkte
beispielsweise hierfür einsetzen erreger
werden von staubpartikeln übertragen
erhöhte ansteckungsgefahr vor allem in
trockenen gebieten sowie übertragungen
flugzeugen das machen wir weil das
flugzeug ist auch der krone wir uns nach
deutschland gelangt und erklärt ich
jetzt einfach mal auf entwickeln und wir
sehen schon ok wir sind jetzt bei stufe
2 das nächste was wir hier haben damit
zu wenig dna punkte im entwurf und ein
schwein
wolfe sind süß und schweine sind auf
süßes
ich will nicht dass das die auch das
virus dann allerdings lege ich jetzt
hier oben rechts auch mal auf symptome
da sehen wir schon haben einmal
schlafstörungen als symptom wer weiß ich
gar nicht ist schlafstörungen unserem
turm von corona virus also ich kann
eigentlich nur lungenerkrankungen das
seht ihr hier schon husten ok
informationen chance auf infektion
nichtverbreitung von der regen in die
umgebung vor allem den besonders dicht
besiedelten urbanen gebieten ja da
klicken wir direkt auf entwickeln
außerhalb von flüssigkeit durch husten
erholt die infektions reise deutlich
kriegt auch auf entwickeln weil das
stimmt wirklich und jetzt habe ich nur
noch zwei dns punkte aber da kann ich
jetzt nicht mehr allzuviel hier machen
wir unseren corona virus kicker auf das
kreuz und wir können das auch die zeit
mal ein bisschen vorspulen also so oder
so jetzt da sich corona virus auf der
welt auszubreiten beginnt verwendet das
welt datenmenge unten rechts und zu
sehen welche länder nicht infiziert sind
noch nicht
im coming for you germany also klickt
man mal hier rechts auf welt und wir
sehen gesund sind gerade noch peru
argentinien bolivien et cetera pp haben
wir können ja auch runter scrollen und
sehen unter anderem gesundes opfer
verdammt ist allerdings mein einziges
ziel heute ist deutschland auszurotten
ich jedoch in deutschland lebe seit ich
will natürlich meine maske auf was mit
der masse gewinne ich einfach sterben in
deutschland noch keinen einzigen
infizierten haben allerdings bereits
zehn punkte und wenn man die wände ich
kriege zur pause lag bei bitte ab was in
china gerade abgeht oder und rousseau
und co wir haben hinten in england auch
schon welche ich spiele das gerade auch
der herzlichste schwierigkeitsstufe
ich stecke hier unten auf jeden fall mal
wieder auf krankheit drauf und jetzt mal
auf die fähigkeiten
wir haben hier beispielsweise eine
virale instabilität die entwickler
weiter weil das soll stabil sein dass
entwickle ich sogar noch mal weiter und
bei den symptomen gehe ich auch nochmal
zu den schlafstörungen weil wenn die
leute nicht schlafen können dass tillich
dann können die infizierten dahinten
meine videos schauen jetzt gehe ich mal
wieder weiter auf play wir beobachten
das ganze jetzt einfach mal die könnte
man hier unter euch die zahlen dann
gucken wir haben über 360 millionen
leute schon infiziert jetzt über 400
millionen also steigert sich wirklich
rasant globale erwärmung heiße länder
werden heißer ja er wird neues der china
ist komplett am arsch also sorry aber
ihr seid ja roter als tomatensoße china
schließt flughäfen ok krass china greift
mittlerweile echt krass durch also es
ist nah an der realität wie die
entwickler ja auch schon neben statement
gesagt haben aber schlussendlich wenn
ihr euch das spiel auch runterladen
im app store
[Musik]
das hört sich ein bisschen an den horror
spiel falls ihr euch das spiel im app
store runterladen sollte das von mir
hierzu überhaupt keine werbung oder so
dass sie das tun sollte da keine ahnung
was aber falls ihr es tun sollte dann
bitte bitte macht euch nicht verrückt
das ist das einzige was ihr euch
mitgeben möchte wenn kein arzt und es
war meine hauptmesse auch immer im
gestrigen video ich will einfach nicht
dass hier alle irgendwie posten wir
werden alle sterben und keine ahnung was
ernährt euch gesund achtet auf eure
hygiene und meidet jetzt natürlich klar
china besonders wo hahn obwohl man da
glaube ich eh nicht reinkommen weil das
komplett abgeriegelt
südafrika bei heilmittel forschung
führen heute darüber
ein paar sekunden später
[Musik]
aber ich wenigstens wehren in
deutschland getötet
ja meine lieben freunde an der stelle wo
ich das heute geht jetzt alles sauber
enden viele von euch hat mir geschrieben
halo kam dass er gestern ein video über
den corona virus gemacht spiel doch dann
heute mal das spiel plugin von da habe
ich mir gedacht die spiels mal ich habe
insgesamt zwei milliarden menschen
getötet allerdings keinen einzigen
deutschen dann schon ziemlich scheiße
eigentlich in dem game wenn ich das
heute wieder allerdings gefallen da
würde ich mich selber einen daumen hoch
von euch freuen schreibt mir gerne in
die kommentare wieder über den ganzen
corona virus und die ganze panikmache
gerade denkt und ja soll ich nächste
woche mich noch mal dazu melden wenn es
irgendwie ein update gab ich bin übers
wochenende auch in london gleich krieg
hat da auch ein bisschen was mit da gibt
es ja auch schon ein paar corona
feldhasen reporterin zu informieren
[Musik]